تجربته واعاني 70 اي يخشى ان تتكرر في
هامبرغر المانيا تكرر نفس اخطاء الطاقه
الروسيه مع الصين والدليل اكملوا بناءا
بحريا في المانيا والاهم ما في اوروبا
شركه اكوسكو الصينيه سمح لها بالاستثمار
في المرفق والقرار اثار معارضه غير مسبوقه
داخل الائتلاف الحاكم الحزب هو
الديمقراطيه الحره
خارجيه هي الاخرى كانت كلها تخوفات هذا
الاستثمار يوسعوا التاثير الاستراتيجيه
والتحكم الصيني في البنيه التحتيه للنقل
في المانيا اوروبا كوسكا الصينيه تمتلك
اصلا حصصا اخرى في اكبر من عيني في اوروبا
في اوروبا
في بلجيكا وبيجانب ميناء ما يجعل السؤال
الابرز هنا ماذا لو غازات الصين تايوان
وفرد الغ هو عقوبات على بكين الاجابه عند
المعهد الاقتصاديه الالمانيه
هل تستبدل المانيا اعتمادها على روسيا
بالصين سؤال متى يؤرق السياسيين الالمان
هنا ويشكل ماده خلافات رئيسيه بين الاحزاب
الحاكمه طفت الى السطح مؤخرا بعد اعلان
المستشار اولاس عن دعمه لمشروع استحواذ
شركه الصينيه لجزء من مرفقه همبرج رغم
اعتراضي الشريكين في الاتلاف الحاكم زياره
شمس الى الصين رافقتها انتقاداتهم لاذعه
من قبل الحزبين المشاركين في الاتلاف
الحكومي الليبراليين والخضر وزير الاقتصاد
روبرتحبك الذي ينتمي لحزب الخضر حذر من
تكرار اخطاء الماضي في ما دعت وزيره
الخارجيه
التي تنتمي ايضا لحزب الخضر الى
استراتيجيه جديده مع الصين